so I first like my sole contact with
Buckley which was a particular
significance as far as I was concerned
was that he invited me to be on a
program at talk program that he ran
called firing line and yes I was invited
and was there for one one program that
was it you can see the program I
understand it's been now appears on the
internet and so on at the end he said he
was pretty angry he said he wouldn't
like me back but of course I never heard
from again
he was he was the maybe the leading
figure in the so-called conservative
movement I don't think the term
conservative is appropriate but what's
called the conservative movement he was
maybe its leading figure he was maybe
its leading it lacked well as journal
was the house Journal he was considered
not by me but he was considered to be
witty articulate knowledgeable and so on
and much respected again not by me but
I'm giving the general impression the
witch calling his successors I assume
you mean the so-called neoconservatives
I mean they're even farther from
conservatism they're just extreme
radical nationalists Wolfowitz pearl
Chaney rest of them it's defaming
conservatism to associate them with
conservatism conservatism as an
honorable tradition but it's not that
same is true Reagan Reagan was believed
in the military violence and destruction
in Central America virtually destroyed
he supported the South Africa's
apartheid regime and violation of
congressional legislation supported its
attacks on neighboring countries that
killed a million and a half people
support of the Israeli atrocities eleven
killed tens of thousands of people and
so on and internally he was in favor of
large-scale government intervention in
the economy
I mean Reagan was the most protectionist
president in post-war American history
with double protectionist barriers
called on the Pentagon to rescue
deficient American management teach them
modern management techniques so that
they could save the economy from
Japanese takeover I mean to call this
conservatism this bad joke
and then neocon so-called or in more
extreme so by today's standards buckley
looks pretty moderate I suppose
you